known for his distinctive soothing
authoritative voice Morgan Freeman has
landed a lot of VoiceOver and narration
work serving as the deao all- knowing
metaphorical voice of God in the shash
Shank Redemption and March of the
Penguins led to Freeman's playing the
personification of the Christian idea of
God in the blockbuster comedies Bruce
Almighty and Evan Almighty one film in
which Freeman didn't play God was Seth
Rogan and Evan Goldberg's star studded
apocalyptic comedy This is the End Rogan
and gold ber wrote A Part just for
Freeman but he turned it down Rogan told
Yahoo entertainment we wanted him to
play God apparently he takes his
character as God very seriously